this guy had a big week huge week he's
damian lillard from my Portland
Trailblazers they're still waiting to
find out who they're gonna play next
round as we have a Game seven
with the Nuggets and the San Antonio
Spurs of course had the big shot against
Oklahoma City to send them packing and
the Portland Trail Blazers guard joins
us on the program if somebody didn't see
what happened this past week how would
you sum it up for them Damian I would
say it was a really intense week we go
from emotional like horrifying wrong a
day in between where it's like man all
right we don't want to go back to
Oklahoma City you need to get this land
you got to wait a whole day before it's
hard to sleep the night before it and
get up our fall game just a wild finish
you know down 15 come back when good
shot and then you know everything is
just going crazy after that so I was
just saying really really intense really
intense week take us into the huddle so
coach gets ready for the final shot what
is said demo I think what was said we
had so we were down to in our last
timeout Paul George was visit a free
throw line jumper and a no huddle coach
told me to break deep you know catch it
in the backcourt
and then try to get it to go on I think
it was like 38 or 39 seconds or any time
we want to get a super-long we call it
33 try to get a shot up about 33 seconds
and I sprained it in the backcourt I got
and I was the only thing he said just
try to get it try to get the to purloin
and we didn't say we're gonna call the
timeout or not if we did score and get a
stop or whatever but usually I tell him
not to call the timeout if we get if we
like get the last shot that's a tie game
because you know you don't want to get a
other team a chance to set up hanger you
came down the ball so I made the layup
to tie it up
with like 32 seconds left they came down
they missed that we got the rebound and
I got the ball and as I was dribbling it
up I just didn't even I don't even look
at the sideline I was like I just
brought it up and you know I looked as I
was bringing it up I got to half court
and I knew I had a lot of time to kind
of just set up and I just saw coach
telling everybody he was putting pushing
him towards the baseline like just go
flat go flat you know and I was don't I
so which was what I'm sure everybody
already had him wearing on our team but
the last year I really wasn't even the
conversation it was more to play before
that to get a get a quick two to try to
tie it up and then get a stop I was
wondering though at what point were you
going to take the shot because Paul
George is looking at the clock on his
end and he realizes that you're not
going to drive now you guys are playing
a little game of chess here and he I
thought he timed it perfectly but you
took the little sidestep and that
created a separation there yeah so I was
I mean he was in front of me
and I was looking at the clock and the
clock was going down and it was like a
lot of space between us and I was like I
got to a spot I drove it over to the
left a little bit like towards the
middle and I was at a spot I was like
his deep but I was comfortable right
there if I could just raise up and just
shoot the ball and he was like a little
bit out and I was looking at the clock
trying to see how long he would stay
that far away from me but then I was
like all right he don't realize that I'm
gonna have to shoot a jump and I'm not
gonna drive if I wait too long so I went
between the legs get on the move a
little bit to my left and I crossed over
right to left between the legs and he
was on on the left side of my body and
then right after I once in the leg it
was like two seconds left and he moved
he was a little bit to my left and I
just saw a step to the right and I got a
clear look at the breath you know he he
contested him pretty good but he was to
the left side of me and I was so it was
like it didn't really have an effect on
on the shot when did you know it was
good
it felt good leaving my hands but you
know I've missed a lot of shots that so
good yeah I just sorta I saw the arc on
the ball and I saw where it was going
and I was like yeah that's gonna does
gonna be back rim or a snow in there so
when you're out early and I was like man
it just happened again it's one thing to
practice a shot though from that
distance Damian it's another thing to
practice with somebody on you so how
often do you practice the shot with
somebody on you as opposed to just
taking a thirty seven foot jumper well
it's funny because like I usually
practice it wide open and like my
trainer sometimes like when we have to
enter the workout sometimes he'll catch
it and he'll like foul me on those like
I'll be shooting it he'll literally like
smack my arm sometimes and sometimes I
just get a little irritated like there's
no way I'm gonna make this shot which
you like hitting my arm that hard
because it's literally like a hard foul
and I hardly ever make those ones that
he found me but I'm just like I get
irritated what it meant sometimes you're
just like you know jump before you can
get ready to shooting just to just to be
there and like throw my rhythm off and
make it uncomfortable and it's not like
we do it a million times but he do it
and it's funny that he's Betty
sometimes just randomly come out there
and contested and just found me from
that distance so I think all of the
stuff that we drew up from that distance
just makes it a little more comfortable
he's the Blazers guard Damian Lillard
Johnny and Stan Patrick show Paul George
called heard a bad shot to that you say
what yes all he said it was a bad shot I
mean I think typically you would say
it's a bad shot but I mean yes that's
what anybody would say that hasn't been
in the behind as many points here what
went into a shot like that you know so
in that situation if the shot was made
on me my response wouldn't be it was a
bad shot but I mean some people think it
was a bad shot but you know it turned
out to be a good shot cause it went you
know what your response should have been
or
should be yeah it was a bad shot and
then you pause and there you go for
everyone else but me that's true but it
feels like you became this overnight
sensation like people who I mean we
followed you we know what you do but it
feels like the casual sports fans like
God did you see the shot by that guy the
other night in Portland it's almost like
I liken it to Odell Beckham jr. 'he's
one-handed catch against the Cowboys he
had been a great player prior to that
but everybody saw that all of a sudden
Odell Beckham jr. became somebody that
people were talking about I think you're
getting the Odell Beckham treatment
right now yeah I remember that moment
because I knew that Beckham was I I know
he was and he was at LSU and then after
that it just seemed like he just kind of
just shot out there you know became a
big star but I don't know if I compared
to that I think it was a big play I
wasn't the first big shot that I made
but I think it's just the situation you
know having 50 points and in a series
against a popular team with popular
players I guess it could be compared to
that but I don't could not just wasn't
oh no
maybe I missed out a little bit cuz I
wasn't on
I just wasn't all over you know the the
drama around it just because I was like
man a series over um and just rest up
you know I kind of took a back seat a
little bit but I also I'm curious about
this it seems like Russell Westbrook
wants to engage he wants to talk
constantly he loves that battle within
the battle where it feels like you pick
your spots with that is is that is that
a fair assessment of your game I know
what his is but is that what you try to
do you pick your spots I mean I don't I
don't think my spots where the battle is
I've got it on there for it it's our
entire time but it's just not going to
be to me the battle is how can I make my
team beat your team you know
and I don't always mean I'm gonna be the
one that's looking like I'm doing what
needs to be done or I'm the one that's
doing the scoring or doing the talking
or all that you know I'm just trying to
make sure I I do what I'm supposed to do
to make my team be successful that's
what it is for me but like I said
earlier I just mounted the series is
over it was funny to me that people
wanted to make it like such a negative
thing between us and it's not we lose
like me and Russ are really cool you
know like off the query we get on the
court I don't expect anything I don't
expect anything else from him and he
doesn't expect anything else from me no
there's no dislike see you got you can't
do that you got to keep this up at least
in our mind that we think there's this
great trash talk rivalry between you two
yeah you can't be playing nice here Dave
really I don't
I'm not playing nice I'm just telling
you what the truth is I don't really
like on the court on the court like I
talked to him and he talked trash to me
and he did you know he rocked the baby
and Dennis Smith I mean Dennis Schroder
captors wrists and all that stuff like
that's all a trash talking all that does
not dislike you know and everybody was
trying to turn it into us not liking
each other and all that stuff when we're
actually pooled so your honor the series
is over I'm just making that I'm just
making that clear okay that's why
there's no issue but you'll have a
personal beef how good was that wave
goodbye though - oh great
it was like I said after the game right
I was just having the last word you know
not a pack of four cups physical it was
they was competing hard and we completed
our SOTA fact that me end it that way no
I felt like it was only right to to do
that but when every when your teammates
swallowed you up after making that shot
and then your your head just kind of
pops up and you look at the camera and
it was such a great picture it was like
I don't know what the big deal is you
know it almost looked like somebody
photoshopped your head in there in that
you know mosh pit there you're just like
what's the big deal yeah it was
it was funny man cuz I anytime I get
like swarms like that and you're in the
bottom of a mosh pit I just went into
survival mode I'm just trying to make
sure on with this mask I can breathe and
I'm not on top of somebody I just was
like I always go into a little baby
panic whenever when I'm in one of those
so I was trying to get myself out and
then I was like looking up and I looked
up and the camera was right there and it
just kind of caught me just right there
and I kind of just not in my head at the
camera but Amazon just happened that way
it was a meme waiting to happen as soon
as I saw your head pop up I went oh boy
they're gonna have fun with that I knew
right away by the way juicy don't get
after the game and I was like that's a
real for sure Charles Barkley picked you
guys to win the West
yes what you got a problem with that no
I have a problem waiting I just you know
we're just gonna play you know I don't
think I'm happy that he feels that way
about us but for us our thing is always
been to not pay attention to all that
stuff and just go out there and play
some people said we wouldn't make the
playoffs for years and every year they
think we don't beat our team out for
some reason you know really we don't pay
attention to it then so now that
somebody says you know something
speaking highly of us we don't we still
don't change it we just still do our
work and go out there and try to get the
job done now if it actually happens then
you know we'll me and Charles I talked
in but it could in we just got to keep
doing yeah but these guys are jumping on
the bandwagon now Damien I was there at
Weber State I mean I was there I said
you know it's like seven seven years
from now this guy's gonna nail a 37
footer to beat a team in the playoffs I
mean we did it though Damon yeah we did
we did it and you know I yeah I called
game when you'd left your hand I turned
the TV off before it went in I didn't
even need to
I'm living I'm like unlike Steph Curry's
brother I'm Seth I'm like hey I'm gonna
tell the bench what's going to happen
and then it happened he told my song
over there telling her back like I told
you hey a lot of fun and good luck
congratulations on it and good luck in
the next round we appreciate your time
as always thank you for having me
Damian Lillard you heard him say we did
it yes we did for more Dan Patrick show
tune in to audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show at